So, we're taking up in volume 11, at Louis' prayer, "Good morning, Jesus."
Okay, it's very good that you get this just before your break, so you have your good morning
and your good night in place, okay?
What comes across is the extraordinary love that is between Louisa and Jesus, it's very
personal, very intimate. Oh my Jesus, sweet prisoner of love, speaking to Jesus in the
Blessed Sacrament. Here I am before you again. I left you saying goodbye and now I come back
saying good morning. Close the front door. I was anxiously burning to see you again in
this prison of love, to give you my yearning obsequise, she says. Now, obsequise are funeral
rites. Okay, which is absolutely amazing. My affectionate heartbeats, my ardent desires
and all of myself in order to transfuse myself completely in you. Now, if she's offering
him, obsequise is obviously a wrong word chosen by the translator, that she wants to
die in him and for him. That's actually what she's talking about. I want to die in him
and for him. What is it? Sorry. Okay. And I want to abandon all of myself in you in perpetual
memory and pledge of my love. Now, everything as far as Louisa is concerned is total gift
of self, total absolute gift. So my beloved sacramental love, while I come to give you
all of myself, I also have come to receive from you all of yourself. Because that's what
love is, total giving on both sides. That's John 1420 to 21, you in me and I in you, both
completely one. It's John 1420 to 21. I cannot live without a life, she says, and therefore
I want yours. Now, when she says I cannot live without a life, her old natural life is dead.
She's already in divine will a long time. Okay, so the old natural life is dead. And
she's living with the life of Christ not with her own. And that is Galatians 220. I live
no longer I, but Christ lives in me Galatians 220. So she said, I have to have a life. So
I want yours. All is given to one who gives all, of course, there's the principle. And
isn't it true, Jesus? She said, therefore today, I will love with your heartbeat of a
passionate lover. I will breathe with your panting breath in search of souls. I will
desire your glory and the good of souls with your own immeasurable desires. All the heart
beats of people will flow within your divine heartbeat. We will grasp them all. And she
can say we because there's only one will between them. We will save them. We will let
nobody escape at the cost of any sacrifice, even if I should bear all the pain. Now, the
way Louisa is praying there is the way Jesus prayed. In other words, that he would save
souls at any cost to himself. Didn't matter what the cost was. So if it's at any cost
to myself, you have the Supreme act of love of neighbor. So Louisa has fulfilled the law
of loving the neighbor right to the nth degree. If you should push me away, I will fling myself
deeper inside. That's inside his heart and inside as well. I will cry out louder in order
to plead together with you for the salvation of your children and my brothers. So now she's
going to go on to a new bit and she says that everything in divine will is souls and love,
souls and love, souls and love. Because you hear me saying that the summary of the whole
36 volumes is divine will and love. And Louisa is adding in the third one that you would
do anything to save souls. Oh my Jesus, my life and my all, how many things does your
voluntary imprisonment? Now notice the voluntary. Nobody asked him to lock himself up in tabernacles
for the whole of human history. Absolutely nobody did it. And he has been telling Louisa
now for 10 volumes that the suffering that is of real value to God is voluntary suffering.
Okay, that's what the victim souls have. So your voluntary imprisonment tells me. But
the emblem with which I see you all studied is the emblem of souls. In other words, this
is why you do it. He's been telling us all the time that the motivation that we must
have and the only one acceptable to him is love. Okay. But his emblem is souls. Everything
is for souls because he is love and the change with chains which bind you completely so very
tightly are love. That's because God is love. So you can put one John four seven to 17 there.
God is love. One John four seven to 17. It seems that the words souls and love, which
you'd have to put inverted commas because it's a statement. It seems that the words souls
and love make you smile. They debilitate you and force you to surrender and everything.
In other words, he'll pay any price for the salvation of souls. And I pondering well these
excesses of your love. She's talking about the blessed Eucharist as one of the greatest
excesses of God's love will always be around you together with you with my usual refrains
souls and love, souls and love. Therefore today, I want all of you always together with me
in the prayer, in the work, in the pleasures, in the displeasure, in the food, in the steps
in the sleep, in everything. So there you have the reason why we have the prayers telling
us to offer absolutely everything for him. So Philippians four nineteen there. I'm certain
that being unable to obtain anything by myself, which is John fifteen five. With you, I will
obtain everything which is Philippians four thirteen. And everything we do will serve to
soothe each of your pains, to sweeten every bitterness of yours, to repair for any offense,
to repay you for everything and to infiltrate any conversion, no matter how difficult and
desperate. We will go begging for a little love from every heart. That's because you
approach people from within, to make you more content and happy. Isn't it good like this,
Jesus? She said. Okay. So, O dear prisoner of love, bind me with your chains, seal me
with your divine love. And there's something that's extremely important for us that we
be sealed in the divine love. Now, many people trying to live a spiritual life, either in
the ordinary sense or at the divine will level. If they're not sealed, you can fall back. Is
that okay? So, seal me with your divine love. Please, show me your beautiful face. Oh, Jesus,
how beautiful you are. Now, it's only the saints who actually know about this beauty.
Remember Saint Augustine? Oh, beauty so ancient and so new. Late have I loved the, that's one
of the famous statements of Saint Augustine. And he's fourth century. How beautiful you
are. Now, that beauty, she isn't saying how handsome you are, because that's what you
would say to a man, isn't it? She's saying beauty. And therefore, she's talking about
something that is internal, that's shining through the humanity. Okay. Your blonde hair,
now she's completely sure that his hair is blonde. Maria Valtorta was sure that the hair
was blonde as well. But in most pictures, you have a brown hair. That's because people
don't know. They're just simply guessing. Your blonde hair braids and sanctifies all
my thoughts. Your forehead, Cam and Serene, in the midst of so many offenses, gives me
peace and puts me in the most perfect cam, even in the midst of the greatest storms. Even
of your very privations, of your whims, she said that a few times, which cost me my life.
Now, beside all of that, I wanted to put song of songs, chapter eight, verse six, song of
songs, chapter eight, verse six, in which the bride is describing the bridegroom, which
is exactly what Louise is doing there. Ah, you know what she said, but I move on. It
is my heart that tells you this, for it knows how to say it better than I do. Oh, love your
beautiful chirulian eyes deep blue. Sorry. Well, chirulian eyes are blue. Okay. That's
the dictionary says, sparkling with divine light, abduct me to heaven. Now, abduct me
to heaven refers to all times it pulls her into an out of the body experience. And you
make me forget the earth, but alas to my greatest sorrow, my exile yet continues. Hurry, hurry
Jesus. Yes, you are beautiful Jesus. I seem to see you in that tabernacle of love. The
beauty and the majesty of your face enamors me and makes me see heaven. Your gracious
mouth kisses me softly in every instant. Your gentle voice calls me and invites me to
love at every moment. This is song of songs chapter five, verses 10 to 16. Your knees sustain
me, your arms clasp me with indacelible bond. I will impress my burning kisses, thousands
upon thousands upon your adorable face. Jesus, Jesus, may our will be one. This is the first
time now she's talking about our will and we. That's very important. It's the beginning
of volume 11. So, may our will be one, may our love be one and our contentment be one.
I've just changed that in English for you. Never leave me alone for I am nothing and
the nothing cannot be without the all. So, that's John 15, five. Without me, you can
do nothing. John 15, five. So, do you promise me, Jesus? She said, it seems that you say
yes and now bless me and bless everyone. And in the company of the angels, the saints
and your sweet mother and of all creatures, I say to you, good morning, Jesus, good morning.
Now you have to be fairly far around to be that fervent very early in the morning. Isn't
that absolutely incredible? So, now she said, after I wrote these prayers written above
under the influence of Jesus is what you need to call her. As he came at nighttime, Jesus
showed me that he was keeping this good by and this good morning inside of his heart.
Okay. And he told me, my daughter, they really came out of my heart, whoever will recite
them with the intention of being with me, as is expressed in these prayers, I will keep
him with me and I will keep him in me to do what I do. Isn't that fantastic? And I will
not only warm him with my love, but each time that you would say the prayers, I will increase
my love towards that soul, admitting him to union with the divine life and with my own
desire to save all souls. So, you need to put a little heading in front of that and that's
Jesus's promise because the next time you look at that page, then the title will invite
you to read it. Okay. So, the next paragraph is that we have to be all for Jesus. I would
want Jesus in my mind, Jesus in my lips, Jesus in my heart. I would want to look only at Jesus.
Here only Jesus be clasped only with Jesus. I want to do everything together with Jesus.
I want to love with Jesus, suffer with Jesus, play with Jesus, cry with Jesus, write with
Jesus. Without Jesus, I don't even want to draw a breath. Isn't that fantastic? I will
stay here like a fussy little girl doing nothing so that Jesus will come to do everything with
me. Content to be his amusement, abandoning myself to his love, to his lashes, to his
worries, to his loving whims as long as I do everything with Jesus. You see my Jesus,
she said, "This is my will." In other words, this prayer declares who I want to be and
what I want to be. "And you will not move me," she said, "Do you hear?" So, come now
and write with me, she says. How is that? So, we have to say to him, come and eat with
me, come and work with me, come and do everything with me. Okay. It makes a difference when you
say come and drive with me. He manages to order the rest of them as well as yourself and make
the place an awful lot safer. I always say to him, "And would you ever protect us all
from each other?" Absolutely. So, February the 14th, 1912, Jesus looks at everything in
the will. Now, what is most important to God? This is a very, very important teaching.
We look at a marvelous building that somebody has built and we say that the builder or the
architect is great. And Jesus says, "No, I don't look at the building. I want to know
why they built it and who they built it for. It's what's in the will that's important
for him. Because you see, you can't take the building to heaven. But you can take the love
to heaven. And we have to keep this in mind all the time. The baggage allowance for heaven
only contains love. We have to keep this in mind. Absolutely. And just the reason why
I use that kind of language is that it is normal language for us, baggage allowance.
Do you know what I mean? If you had said that a hundred years ago, nobody would have known
what you were talking about. So, Louisa says, "Continue in my usual state, my beloved Jesus
came and I was saying to him, 'Tell me Jesus, how is it that after you have disposed the
soul to suffering and knowing the goodness contained in it, she loves suffering. She
suffers almost with passion. And while she believes that suffering is her inheritance,
all of a sudden you take this treasure away from her." Now, here's my suggestion. I don't
think that came from Louisa. I think that came from the priests. And I think an awful
lot of her questions came from the priests who needed to understand. Whereas Louisa is
a very, very simple soul herself. And she would let the Lord do it. He wants, "You know
that from the prayer we've just had." Okay. So, this to me has to be a query that's coming
from the priests. They want to know why she was suffering in an awful lot at an early
stage. And now she appears to be suffering very little. So, we're going to get a vital
spiritual teaching here from the Lord. Jesus said, "My daughter, number one, my love is
great. Number two, my rule is insuperable, incapable of being overcome. Number three,
my teachings are sublime. Number four, my instructions are divine, creative, and inimitable. Now,
I think if he was answering Louisa directly, just for herself, he wouldn't have used words
like that. But if he's talking to the priests, he would. So, he's going to go down through
these four. "Therefore, so that all things be they great or small, painful or enjoyable,
natural or spiritual, may acquire one single color and a one single value, once the soul
has practiced suffering." Watch this now. "And reaches the point of loving it," which
is where Louisa is at. "I let this suffering pass into her will as her own property." Your
will is your highest faculty. "So, every time I send her suffering, having the property
and the dispositions within her will, she will always be disposed to suffer and to love
it. I look at things in the will. And it is as if the soul were always suffering." In other
words, when all this practice is over, Jesus shifts the reality onto a higher plane. And
it's in the will. So, whether you suffer or you don't, he said, as far as he's concerned,
you are continuously doing it because it has shifted onto this higher plane where everything
remains. Okay? And he said, "I look at things in the will as if the soul were always suffering
even if she doesn't suffer." Now, if you remember St. Therese of Les Eu, she voluntarily
locked herself up in a monastery for the short period of her life. Okay? "When she had reached
a certain level of union with God, she said to the Lord, 'I would like to be a priest
and do all the work that priests do. I'd like to be a missionary and do all the work that
missionaries do. I'd like to be this, that the other and the Lord said, 'Don, you desire
it. I do it.'" Isn't that amazing? We don't tell the Lord often enough what we would like
to do if you had the possibility, because I've often heard people say, "Well, I couldn't
do that because I'm married and I have to stay here. I got my family and I got my duties
to my family." But what they don't realize is that spiritually you can do it because
he does it for you if you desire it truly and therefore all the limitations of our lives
are taken away. Isn't that absolutely fantastic? I'd love to be able to heal the sick. He
says if you really, sincerely, and the depths of your being really, really want to do that,
then he kicks in and he does it. Isn't that fantastic? It's just that we need to sort
out what it is because people often say, "I'd love to do that, but there's no possibility
at all of doing it because of my circumstances or whatever." We don't realize that in the
divine will that limitation is removed. Isn't it amazing? So what you're going to do now?
So every time I look at things in the will and it is as if the soul were suffering, even
if she doesn't suffer, and so that pleasure may have the same value as suffering as well
as praying, working, eating, sleeping, and so on everything because everything lies in
whether things are from my will so that all things may have the same value. I allow the
soul to practice all things in my will with holy indifference that it doesn't matter whether
you're suffering or enjoying yourself. So it seems to the soul that I give her something
and then I take it away from her, but it's actually not true. Rather, it happens that
at the beginning, when the soul is not yet well trained, she feels sensitivity and suffering
in praying and in loving. But when through practice, these things pass into her will as
her own property or sensitivity ceases. And the extraordinary thing is that at this very,
very high level, you can be praying very intensely and there's no thought and there's no word.
And you may appear to have no visions, no revelations, no nothing. You're just being
there, but because everything has now lodged in your will, everything is happening. Am
there any sense? Okay, it's terribly important. But people at a very early stage in the prayer
life have all kinds of experiences of darkness and light and dryness and fervor and erudity
and all kinds of stuff. That's when they're in training. And you take somebody much, much
further on and they have a very, usually a very tranquil experience where it appears
as if there's nothing going on. Okay. Maybe if I give you this example, it's not a wonderful
example, but in the very early stages of a relationship between a man and a woman, it's
all very dramatic. But if you take them 40 years later, it's actually quite calm, but
they've accomplished an enormous amount. And an awful lot can be said with no words. One
of the things that really impressed me when I was a child, we lived in a tiny house much
smaller than this house, I can tell you. And we all had to fit in this one room. And so
we had great order in the place because my dad is absolutely insisted on it. And you
have all of us sitting around the table doing our homework. And my mother and himself would
be sitting on either side of the fire in silence while this was going on, because he wouldn't
allow any sound while we were trying to think. Absolutely wouldn't allow it. And then after
a while, I'd look at the two of them and they were completely tranquil, not a word, literally
not a word being said. And I remember one night, my mother suddenly getting up and saying,
I'll make you a cup of tea, which sounded good. My dad said, why did he spoil it? We
were all one. The whole lot was we were all one in this silence. And that was a huge revelation
for me. And as you can see, it never went out of my head. Now I was, I was only primary
school at the time. And my mother never ever made that mistake again. She left us without
the cup of tea. She realized that what was more precious was this unity that we had in
silence. The only time that silence was broken, if one of us got completely stuck. And we usually
turn to the dad to solve the problem. But it's this kind of thing that we need to look
at the fact that when a relationship is mature, it doesn't need all the words. And I talk
in language. It doesn't need all the words. It actually doesn't need all the drama. At
the beginning, you're building the relationship. You're trying to find out who you want to
be and where you want to go and so on. Now, it's the same thing spiritually as well. And
therefore, people at a very early stage in the prayer life need to know a lot of help
with prayer. And they think it's all over when they get their first aridity and I always
laugh. I say, you mean you got your first Monday morning? There's lots more Monday mornings
coming. So her sensitivity ceases. Okay. And when the need arises for her to use these
divine properties, which I made her acquire, with firm step and imperturbable heart, she
begins to exercise them as the opportunity comes. In other words, if Jesus asks Louisa
to carry some suffering, she says, yes, it's no big deal. But what she's got to do now
is be just as tranquil when he doesn't give it to her because he's going to move her
away completely from that into a new vocation altogether. For example, does suffering come?
She finds within herself the strength and the life of suffering. Does she pray she finds
within herself the life of prayer and so with all the rest. So we now get an explanation
in the next paragraph. According to what Jesus says, Louisa says, it seems to me, it's like
this, let us suppose that I have received a gift until I make up my mind on where I should
keep that gift. I look at it, I appreciate it, I feel a certain sensitivity in loving
that gift. But if I keep it under lock and key, no longer watching it, the sensitivity
ceases. But the I don't see the heart don't fail. Okay. However, with this, I cannot say
that the gift is no longer mine. On the contrary, it most certainly is mine because I keep it
under lock and key. Well, before it was in danger and someone might have stolen it from
me. So isn't that interesting? What's happening now is that you're not actually looking at
it. You're not examining it. You're not saying am I in aridity or am I in fervor? Am I this
am I that am I? The concentration has gone completely off yourself and you're only looking
at the Lord. So Jesus then continues, in my will, all things are in balance. I'm trying
to put English on what I'm looking at. All things are in balance. And he's going to tell
us from here on in that everything inside of us must be balanced. Anger is one of the
very powerful emotions that we have. And it can get out of balance quickly. But if anger
and all the other responses that we have are balanced with each other, you'll use anger
correctly because sometimes it is actually necessary to say something strong and powerful
to another person, you know what I mean? So that there's there's real power behind what
you're saying. And there's a way of saying no and everybody knows it's no. And there's
a way of saying no in which everybody knows you're up for negotiation or that you actually
don't mean it at all. And so using anger correctly is really powerful because when you want to
say no strongly, everybody hears it. And then there's no need for any more conversation.
Everything has to be in balance. Now, we are on volume 11. And in the early volumes, Jesus
had spoken about someone who is fervent one day and is not even interested in another
day who pray one time and they're not interested or they'll do good and they're not interested.
That life is out of balance or a person who is married and has a family and spent all their
time in stuff no matter even if it's good outside the family. That's not balance because
there's no balance in the commitment. Is that okay? And the so-called good works can
just be an escape and instead of facing thing. So everything has to be in balance. So as
we go forward from here, everything has to be in order and it has to be balanced just
like it is in God Himself. And to all look alike and all in accord and He's talking about
all the virtues, everything must be in balance. Therefore, suffering gives its place to pleasure.
Now if you talk to someone in the early stages of the spiritual life, that's a contradiction
in terms. They think there must be no pleasure at all. You know what I mean? People who just
do not understand God will say that. People who have had great experience of God knows
that God is the author of everything. And if God has given us the ability to enjoy something
and you absolutely refuse to use it, well it's the same thing as refusing to use anything
else. So it must be balanced. So someone who only wants only wants suffering. That's completely
out of balance. So in the volumes leading up to here, you've seen that when Jesus would
ask a lot of suffering of Louisa, He would be with her the whole time. He'd never leave
her. He was strengthening her. He was encouraging her and empowering her all the time. And then
afterwards, they would have these very fervent moments of pouring love out to each other.
And the two were balanced. It's actually terribly important. Okay. So everything has got to be
imbalanced. Therefore suffering gives its place to love. That's a pleasure. I've done
my part in the will of God. Now you do yours. And only if Jesus wants it, I will enter into
the field again. Number two, fervor says to coldness, you will be more ardent than me
if you content yourself in staying in the will of God in my eternal love. Prayer will
give way to work, sleep, to vigil, illness to health, everything. In other words, everything
is imbalanced. You're not absolutely putting one thing over all the others. And what's
the one thing that holds them all together? It's the divine will. And if it's in the divine
will, Jesus says prayer has the same value as work, sleep has the same value as vigil,
suffering the same value as pleasure, everything. Okay. So all things among themselves, it seems
that each one leaves its place to the other to be present in the field, though each one
has its own distinct place as well. So it's not necessary for one who lives in my will
to move in order to place herself in the act of doing what I want. In other words, you
don't have to go anywhere. You don't have to do any special ritual. She's already in
me like an electric wire doing whatever I want. Now, one of the things I love about
him is that as soon as an invention has come on board, he takes it on board. So if your
house is wired for electricity, you leave it wired. You don't actually unwire it. You
just do it once. And he says, you get into my will, do it once, it balances everything.
But I love the fact here, because you won't find this in many spiritual writings that
pleasure and suffering have the same value. There are many people, many people who think
that if you take coffee and a biscuit in Lent, that there's something really wrong with you,
that you really are failing God. I'm deliberately using that example because everybody says,
"Biscuits in Lent." I said to someone about biscuits in Lent, there's no connection between
biscuits in Lent. No, not so ever. Between Lent and self-denial, yes. Between Lent and
mortification, yes. But between biscuits in Lent, no. But we can make a connection like
that and it can even turn into a judgment of another person, you know. So February the
second, 1912, I don't know what date it is, it's February anyway, the offering of a victim.
You in my usual state, my adorable Jesus made himself seem crucified with the soul. We're
on the next message, with the soul near him who was offering herself to Jesus as a victim.
And Jesus said, this is very important because some people, I've actually come across people
who've offered themselves to God as a victim. And I say, are you absolutely certain that
you know what you're doing? Because I think it's just a moment of fervor and they have
no idea that the consequences would be drastic. So Jesus now talks to this person who wants
to offer herself as a victim. My daughter, I accept you as a victim of pain. That means
if she's a victim of pain, she's going to have that for the rest of her days. Everything
you may suffer, you will suffer as if you were with me on the cross. Well, if you're
not ready for that, you don't make the offering. And with your sufferings, you will relieve
me. Many times this relieving of me with your sufferings escapes you, he said, because she's
now ready for this. No, however, that I was a peaceful victim and host. So if I offer
myself to the Lord and accept to be a victim of pain, and all of a sudden I'm wondering
why I'm getting all these headaches and why my back is killing me and why I can't walk
and all the rest of it and I have all this pain. And I start getting depressed and upset.
Am I ready? No. He said, you have to be a peaceful one. In other words, you have to
be ready for this. So you don't make an offering like that unless you're ready. Because you've
heard me say before, don't say to God what you're not ready to actually do. He said,
I don't want you an oppressed victim. In other words, you start getting depressed because
of all the pain. That means you're not ready for this because you see how much Louisa has
suffered and has agreed to suffer, but it never caused her depression and it never made her
on peaceful. He said, I want you peaceful and joyful. I want you to be like a docile
little lamb with your bleeding. That is your prayers, your sufferings and your works. And
it will serve to exude my embittered wounds. Okay. So a person who's offering themselves
therefore must be peaceful and joyful. Okay. I want to give you two Corinthians nine seven
there. Two Corinthians nine seven says God loves a cheerful giver. Okay. And one of the
things that reading any of the saints, they will tell you that God does not want a sour
saint. He's concerned you're not in the school if the sourness is there because the sourness
is not part of the kingdom of God. So February the 18th, our soul who lives out of the life
of Jesus can say that her life is ended. That's your Galatians 2 20 there. I no longer live.
Finding myself in my usual state, my always and all lovable Jesus came and he told me,
my daughter, everything you do for me, even a breath enters into me as a pledge of your
love for me. Now even a breath, even a movement. And I in exchange give you my pleasures of
love. Therefore the soul can say, I live from the pledges of my beloved that my beloved
Jesus gives me. Okay. So to use language which we'll have a little bit further on, Jesus
has by located himself into Louisa. He says, I'm living my actual life in you. Okay. And
he's living his own life on earth through Louisa. And he's continuing his own mission
to save souls and to suffer and to die and to rise again to continue redemption. That's
the very special thing that's going on between Jesus and Louisa and what he wants to do with
us as well, quite literally by locate himself in us. Then he added, my beloved daughter,
since you live from my life, it can be said that your life is ended, that you no longer
live that quite literally that's a quotation from Galatians 2 20. So since it is no longer
you who lives, but I, anything they do, they are the priests, the people who are guiding
Louisa, anything they do to you, pleasing or displeasing, I receive as if it were done
directly to me, acts nine five acts nine five, soul you are persecuting me. Matthew 25 40,
whatever you do to the least of my brethren is done to me. Do you remember? So whatever
the priest do to you, pleasing or displeasing, I receive as if it was done directly to me.
And you can understand from this, from the fact that whatever the priests do to you,
whether pleasing or displeasing, you don't feel anything. Now, the fact that she doesn't
feel anything doesn't mean that her senses are dead. It means that there has been a genuine
exchange of life Jesus is actually living his life in her. And therefore, the sensitivity
that we would normally have to these external stimuli, Jesus has picked it up as not absolutely
incredible. This is why she can live in ecstasy most of the time, when she continuously says
I was in my usual state, she's in an ecstatic state. And in an ecstatic state, you don't
feel external stimuli. This means that there must be someone else who feels that pleasure
or displeasure. And who else could feel it, if not myself, who lives in you and loves
you very, very much. That means he has biolocated himself into Louisa. It's an absolutely extraordinary
thing. This is the first time in history that has happened to somebody who was born with
the original sin. So, February the 24th, 1912, the soul who lives in the divine will lose
his heart temperament. That's her characteristic way of doing things and acquires that of Jesus.
Now, in the past, we used to say of people, they have become very Christ-like. That means
you've acquired the characteristics of Christ. That's what he's talking about here. Notice
I said in the past, unfortunately. After I saw various souls around Jesus, especially
one who is more sensitive, you see, more sensitive means at an earlier stage. He said, "My daughter,
if the souls with the sensitive temperament start doing good, they make more progress
than the others because their sensitivity leads them to arduous and great enterprises."
Now, a very sensitive person is guaranteed to suffer hugely, because everything affects
them at a level that it doesn't affect other people. But if they turn that all over to
the Lord, they have the potential to become great saints. Whereas a person who doesn't
feel like that hasn't got the same stimulus. So, Louisa said, "I prayed that he would
take what was left of her human sensitivity away from that soul, and that he would clasp
her more closely to himself and tell her that he loved her. He would conquer her completely,
and she would hear that he loved her." You'll see that you will succeed, Louisa said, "Have
you not conquered me in this way, telling me that you loved me very, very much?" And
Jesus said, "Ah, yeah, yeah. I'll do it." But I want her cooperation, you know, that
she escapes as much as she can from the people who excite her sensitivity, if you have a coloring
thing colored. In other words, if you really want the Lord to take over, you've got to
escape the people who are driving you mad, and therefore keeping you all the time in
crisis, the people who excite her sensitivity. Now, when I read that first, I remembered
a statement from Thomas at Campus, what was the imitation of Christ? Do you remember?
It's the only bit I remember out of the entire book, and it said, "When I go out among men,
I come back less a man. In other words, you go into a crowd, and you've got all the problems
that are in that crowd, and all the multiple motivations, and all the rest of it. If you
want to live a prayer life, you mustn't expose yourself too much to the crowd. You must learn
how to stay on the path that you're on." I think it's very interesting. I want her cooperation
that she escapes as much as she can from the people excite her sensitivity, and therefore
that her sensitivity is more exposed to what God can do with her. So, Louisa added, "My
love, tell me, what about my temperament? What is it?" I love this. Now, it's a very
good response. Jesus said, "One who lives in my will, which is Louisa, loses her temperament
and acquires mine." So, you may start out as a very sensitive person. That's not where
you're going to end. So, "In the soul who lives in my will, one finds a pleasant, attractive,
penetrating, dignified temperament, and simple at the same time, of a childlike simplicity,
and some, it's like me and everything." First of all, I want to give you Matthew 18 verses
1 to 3. I want you to become like little children. Now, look at the list that the Lord
gives us there, a pleasant temperament. Now, the pleasant temperament is not giving you
the bad weather forecast all the time. Do you know what I mean? And it's not over, sunny,
either. It's pleasant. It's balanced. Attractive. It draws people to itself. If you read the
gospel, children were very attracted to Jesus. And children are pretty good at sounding
out adults, but they like them or not. Penetrating. It's very, very deep. It's dignified. That's
very wonderful. He said, "Looks like me and everything." Even more, she keeps her own
temperament within her power as she wants and as it is needed. Now, the fact that his
temperament takes over doesn't mean that yours dies. It means that yours is in the background
and his is in the foreground. In other words, we're free. Everything that he tells us, we're
free. And the difference between the way God deals with us and Satan deals with us is that
Satan takes your freedom away. If you let him in at all, if you let him in on any particular
area, he will take it over. If you take someone now with a problem with anger and they are
showing this wrong anger a lot of the time, Satan comes in and makes it worse, makes it
worse, and gradually they lose, sorry. They reach a point where they have less and less
and less power over the anger. If you put that anger into the Lord's hands, what happens
is that you gain more and more and more and more control over the anger. But your will
is completely free, whereas Satan uses the anger to make your will weaker and weaker
and weaker, until you have no control. It's just very important to see how the two work.
Because in dealing with people, you'll see this in their lives and you'll be able to
give them advice. So we're always free. But since she lives in my will, she takes part
in my power. So she has all things at herself at her disposal and according to the circumstances
and the people she deals with, she takes my temperament and applies it. So for example,
you meet somebody who is a very, happens to be a difficult person for you and that person
would draw out maybe the worst out of you. If you're living in the divine will, you can
call on Jesus's temperament to deal with that person. Okay, so I want to give you two
Corinthians six, ten as having nothing we actually possess everything. Two Corinthians six, ten.
So Louisa said, tell me, will you give me a first place in your will? That should remind
you of two young gentlemen who got their mother to ask Jesus, can we be first in your kingdom?
And he said, you don't know what you're asking. And the strange thing, I never thought Louisa
would actually ask him. And he smiled and he said, yes, I promise you. Because the answer
to the question of James and John, Jesus said, no, no, my father is the one who determines
who's on the right and on the left. And the extraordinary thing is you discover in these
writings that the person on the right is blessed mother who brought redemption to the world
by bringing Jesus into the world. And the one on the left is Louisa, who brought the
divine will down to the world. And that's not what have been anywhere on the radar of
those two lads. Okay. Things aren't just not what they seem. So Jesus said, yes, I promise
you, I will never let you go out of my will, and you will take and do whatever you want.
And Louisa said, Jesus, I want to be poor, poor, little, little. I want nothing, even
of your own very things that there's something very, very unusual. Because if you've been
in charismatic prayer groups, they want all kinds of gifts, they want ministries, they
want this, they want that, they want the other, they want leadership, they want, they want
they want, which tells you that they're ordinarily staged. And here's Louisa saying, I want nothing
but yourself. It is better if you keep them, she said, I want only you. And as I need things,
you will give them to me, isn't it true? And Jesus said, bravo, my daughter. Finally,
I have found someone who doesn't actually want anything. Because most people go to God
with a shopping list. Everyone wants something from me, she said, but they don't want all.
They don't want me from myself alone. Now we all know the pain of somebody wanting stuff
from you, but now actually wanting you. And we all find that a great pain that somebody
finds it useful to be near you or useful to be connected to you or useful to use your
name or whatever. And all of that is agony. Every single person wants to be loved just
for themselves. Okay. And you see that loving a person just for themselves in the love that's
given to an infant. The infant can't give you anything back except a smile. And then
they learn how to give you love. And the amazing thing is you love them just for being who
they are. Okay. So Jesus said, everyone wants something from me, but not the all. That is
for myself alone. But you by wanting nothing have wanted everything. And here is all the
finest and the astuteness of true love, that by wanting God for himself alone, she actually
receives everything, including the kingdom of the divine will. So you can put beside
that God alone, suffice it. God alone. S U F F I C I T H is the exact words of Teresa
Vavala. 16th century. God alone, suffice it. Nothing else. When we get to that stage,
you'll be amazingly free and happy. So February, the 26th, 1912. This is about love, because
the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love. So we have to keep coming back to
love. My daughter, I am love. Now if you remember back to volume one and two, I am faith, I
am hope, I am charity, I am patience, I am obedience. Here he says, I am love. And I
made my children all love. Their nerves, bones, flesh are woven with love. And after I wolf
them with love, I made blood flow in all of their particles, as though covering them with
the garment in order to give them the life of love. So the human creature is nothing
other than a complex of love. And she does not move other than out of love. We know that
don't we? It's love that makes the world go around. And everything's impossible if there's
no love and marriage is impossible without love. Everything's impossible without love.
At the most, there can be varieties of love, but it's always out of love that she moves.
Watch this now, because the love can go astray, can't it? There can be divine love. There can
be love of self. There can be love of creatures. There can be evil love, but always love. Nor
can she do otherwise, because her life is love created by the eternal love and therefore
led by love as by an irresistible force. So after all, even in evil, even in sin, there
must be love. It's absolutely amazing. What he means is love of money, love of power,
love of pleasure, love of myself, whatever, but it's love of. He said, even in, even in
sin, there has to be love that pushed the creature to do that evil. Isn't it amazing?
So I am my daughter. What is not my sorrow in seeing the human creatures, the property
of my love, which I delivered, being profaned and contaminated by a different use? That's
like saying that you gave a most incredible gift to somebody, and you see them using it
in the most base way, do you know what I mean? They just throw it there, and they use the
gift as if it had no value, and they're using it in such a way as to insult the giver. That's
what he's saying. In order to guard this love which came out of me and which I gave to them,
I remain around them like a poor beggar. And as the person moves, palpitates, breathes,
works, speaks, walks, I go begging for everything from her. And I beg her, I implore her, I beseech
her to give everything to me, saying to her, "Daughter, I ask you, I ask from you nothing
other than what I gave you. It is for your own good. Do not steal from me what is mine.
Your very breath is mine." That's Genesis 2.7. Genesis 2.7. "Your very breath is mine.
Breathes only for me. Your heartbeat and movement are mine. Palpitate and move only for me,
and so with all the rest. And to my greatest sorrow, I'm forced to see the heartbeat taking
one way and the breath another. And I, poor beggar, remain on an empty stomach, while
the love of self, the love of creatures, the love of passions remain full." That's the
wrong use. It's very interesting, isn't it? So the Lord is saying there in very flowery
language, actually, that if we don't hand ourselves over completely to him, we're in
danger of the whole thing going awry. And he said, "Can there be a greater wrong to
God and to ourselves than this? My daughter, I want to pour out my love and my sorrow with
you. Now, with you means the victim soul. Only one who loves me can compassionate me."
Now, when he says one who loves me in these writings, he's usually talking about the
victim soul who loves to the point of suffering for others. So, February the 28th, 1912, we're
going to have discernment, okay? "This morning, as my adorable Jesus came, I said to him,
'Oh, my heart, my life and my all, how can one know whether one loves you only or others
also?" And this is a very important question. "How do I know I actually love God? And how
do I know if I love him all by himself?" So the next paragraph is true love for Jesus.
It's the answer to it. It's true love for Jesus. "My daughter, if the soul is completely filled
with me up to the brim, to the point of overflowing outside, that is, if she thinks of me, searches
for me, speaks about me and loves nothing but me, it seems that everything else does not
exist for her. Rather, it bores and it bothers her. At the most, she gives the scraps the
last place to that which is not God, as if it were her last thought, word, or act for
a necessary thing of the human life." So the very first thing he says is if God is the
very centre of everything you do, yes, you're there. So that's Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10.
You love the Lord your God with all your heart, all your soul, all your mind, and all your
being. Okay. And the scraps to human nature means that you've got to take care of your
body, you've got to look after stuff, you know what I mean? But you're not doing it
as the central thing. Everything is concentrated on God. But if you have to go to the dentist,
you go. And if you have to go to the doctor, you go, do you know what I mean? But it's
not central. It's what your relationship with God that's central. This is what the saints
do is what Jesus said. So it means that the primary focus is on the Lord. I did it too
with myself and with the apostles, giving some dispositions on where to spend the night
and what to eat. Giving this to one's nature does not harm either, does no harm either
to love or to true sanctity, but it is a sign that the creature loves me only. So in other
words, you look after your body and you look after your life, but that's not the centre.
Then the centre, the focus is actually God. Now in the next paragraph, he'll always give
you the negative after the positive. So in the next paragraph, we have the problem of
a divided heart. And I want to give you some references for a divided heart. Isaiah 1,
5. Isaiah 1, 5 and 6, 10. And Jeremiah 17, 10. 17, 10. And Jose 10, 2. Jose 10, 2.
The prophets of Israel have an awful lot to say about the divided heart. But if the soul
alternates among various things the Lord said, "At one time she thinks of me and then of
something else." Or she speaks about me and then she speaks at length about something
else and so with all the rest. It's a sign that she doesn't love me only and I'm not
content with it. So what he's saying here is that you give some attention to the Lord
and you give lots of attention to other things besides. Then if only her last thought, her
last word and her last act is from me, it's a sign that she does not love me. Her last
word, last thought and last, I think is best illustrated this way. It's an Irish joke
and it's about two women who come out in the morning and greet one another and one says
to the other, "How is your mother?" And the other one says, "Oh, we got the priest
for her last night." And the first one says, "Oh, didn't think she was that bad. You don't
need a priest and you don't need God unless she's on her last breath." That's what's
being illustrated here. That God is not in the center of that life. It's only what I
call hellfire insurance. Yeah, exactly. So it's the last thought, the last word and the
last act. In other words, God's last is not first. It's a sign that she doesn't love me
and if she gives me anything at all, she gives me nothing but scraps. Yet this is what most
people do. That bit you need to color. And very particularly if you think of people who
turn up for hatch, match and dispatch. They're not giving much to God, are they? Am I daughter?
Those who love me are united with me like the branches united to the trunk of a tree.
John 15 verses 1 to 10. I am the vine and you are my branches. John 15 verses 1 to 10.
On there ever be separation, oblivion or different nourishment between the branches and the trunk,
their life is one, their purpose is one and the fruits are the same. Even more, the trunk
is the life of the branches and the branches are the glory of the trunk. So I want to give
you Galatians 5, 22 for the fruits. It's the fruits of the spirit you see and if you take
the image of the vine and the branches, it's the sap that produces this life. I love the
fact that the branches are the glory of the trunk. There was a story told about Gandy at
one stage. They asked him why wouldn't he become a Christian? I can't give you the whole lot.
And he said, I like your Christ, but I don't like your Christians. He said, your Christ
is fine. I have no problem with your Christ and I have come across that with other Hindus
as well. I like your Christ, I don't like your Christians. In other words, we are not
producing the fruits that make other people want to take them. You see, so the branches
are the glory of the trunk. Another way that that is illustrated is using an image now
from John chapter 10 and that is that in Israel at the time of Christ, shepherds looked after
the sheep of all the farmers around. They didn't look after sheep belonging to themselves because
sheep had to travel quite long distances to be fed. So if the sheep were healthy and woolly
and fat and all the rest of it, they said it was a good shepherd. But if the sheep were
scrawny and didn't look healthy and all the rest said it was a bad shepherd, so the sheep
were the fruits of the work of the shepherd. They actually advertised who the shepherd
was. So the branches are the glory of the trunk. And if we can say that to all the apples
were great this year, you see the fruits were good. So this is how souls who love me are
with me, he said. Now notice we are getting a good deal of discernment and sorting out
before we get into the deep stuff. It's very interesting how he does it. This is all preparation
and stuff. Okay. So March the 3rd, 1912, the temperament of Jesus is formed by his will.
In other words, if Jesus's temperament is to be shown in me, how will it happen? Everything
happens in his will. Okay. And he's going to be, remember we were talking about balance
a few minutes ago, now we're coming back to it, he's just going to use a different word,
harmony or music. Jesus said, "My daughter, one who does my will loses her temperament
and acquires mine." See we've already been told that in your head you'd say, "How can
this happen?" And since in my temperament there are many melodies which form the paradise
of the blessed such that music is my sweet temperament, music, the goodness, music, the
sanctity, music, the beauty, music, the power, music, the wisdom, music, the immensity and
so on with the rest of my being. Why are they using the word music? They mean harmony.
Everything is an absolute harmony. Okay. Now anybody who's had an out of the body. Anyone
who's had a death experience can have experience the harmony that's in heaven. I've experienced
it because I had a death experience. And I remember hearing the harmony of the angels.
And it was so incredible that I can't listen to music. Because to me it's not harmonious
by comparison to what I heard. It's like as if you had a hundred or a thousand orchestras
all together in harmony. And yet you had millions of voices all together in harmony.
And we have our scales. But they had dozens of scales up and down. There seemed to be
no limit to how high you could go or how low you could go. It was mesmerizing, mesmerizing.
The only music I can personally tolerate is the very, very best of classical. Beyond that
I can't take it. Because I hear the disharmony.
So what Jesus is saying here is that when we let his divine will operate in our world,
let his divine will operate in us to bring everything into harmony. That that's what
makes that person very attractive to anybody. It's just to see the sheer harmony in that
person's life. And he says that in heaven they hear it as a note belonging to his harmonies.
Each one of us is a little musical note. I think it's fascinating, you know. But everything
in heaven is in order and is harmony. I just want to give you a few references for make
music for the Lord. Make music for the Lord. Sam 49, 4. Sam 146, the whole other version
of it. 46, 147, 148, 149, and 150. The last five Sams in the Psalter are just pure music,
praise and glory to the Lord. Okay. So all this coming into divine harmony is us becoming
another Christ. Okay. So Jesus continues. As she goes along doing even the smallest actions,
she makes a melody for me. And as I hear it, I immediately recognize that it is music because
it's in the right place at the right time, at the right level, that everything is right
about it, that the soul has taken from my will, that is from my temperament. And I run to listen
to it. And I like it so much that I am very pleased and cheered from all the wrongs that
others do to me. Isn't that interesting? So he said, my daughter, what will happen when
these little melodies pass into heaven? Because he says everything done and these will last
forever. I will put the soul in front of me, he said, I will play the music and she'll play
her own. And we will dart through each other. And my image of that is of a parent and a small
child playing the same instrument at different levels. But that the child has learned to
put in a few notes in harmony with the adult. And the adult has learned how to play around
the child. Am I talking English? That's what I think it is. There are little notes put
in with his. I will play the music and she'll play her own. We will dart through each other.
The sound of one will be the echo of the sound of the other. The harmonies will mix together.
In clear notes, it will be known to all the blessed that this soul is nothing other than
the fruit of my will, the portent of my will. A portent is really a prodigy, a miracle.
And all of heaven will enjoy one more paradise. Now the paradise is the soul in union with
the divine will. These are the souls to whom I keep repeating. Had I not created the heavens
for you alone, I would create them. That actually is something that if you're needing
a bit of encouragement, you need to take it off the page and write it on to something
that you can pick up, stick it on to your desk or something. That for someone who would
live in the divine will, Jesus said, if he hadn't made the heavens, he'd go and do it
for you. It's now amazing. In them, I lay the heaven of my will and I will make of them
the true images of myself. That's Romans 829. Romans 829. Now let me give you the words
that the church uses for true image. Vero icon. V-E-R-O is true and I-C-O-N is image.
That's why there's a certain lady called Veronica. But Veronica wasn't her name. Her name was
Nikke. And because Jesus left his true image on her cloth, on his way to Calvary, she's
only ever remembered as Veronica, the true image of Christ. So Vero icon, he wants to
make each one of us an image. That's very interesting that somebody looking at you would
be reminded of Christ. That's a very, very powerful way of drawing souls to God. Very
powerful. In fact, I think it's more powerful than words that they're actually just drawn.
I will make them true images of myself. And within these heavens, I keep wandering about
enjoying myself and playing with them. Now these heavens are the heavens of the divine
will. And I think that should be a small h because it's us. I keep wandering about enjoying
myself and playing with them. That's Proverbs 8, 31. Proverbs 8, 31. To these heavens, and
I think again, that should be a small h, I repeat, had I not left myself in the Holy
Sacrament of the Eucharist for you alone, I would have done it. So that's Romans 8, 19.
That the whole of creation is waiting for these people to show themselves. In fact, they
are my true hosts. And just as I could not live without a will, in the same way, I cannot
live without these heavens of my will, small h. I don't blame the type of forgetting confused.
I cannot live without these heavens of my will. So put a little note there in the margin and
say that's us because you might get confused the next time you read it. Rather, they are
my true hosts, but my Calvary and they're not only my true hosts, but my Calvary and
my very life. These heavens of my will, small h, are more dear to me and more privileged
than the Tabernacles and the very consecrated hosts in them. Because in the host, my life
ends as the species is consumed. While in these heavens, small h of my will, my life never
ends. Even more, they serve as my hosts on the earth and will be my eternal hosts in heaven.
These are the living hosts. To these heavens of my will, small h, I add, had I not incarnated
myself in the womb of my mother. For these souls alone, I would have incarnated myself
and for them, I would have suffered my passion in it. What a big envy beside that. That someone
living in his divine will is so precious to him. He would have done it just for them.
It's absolutely amazing. Because in them, I find the true fruit of my incarnation and
passion. That's what he thinks of people living in the divine will. I'm heading for
this for myself now. What he has done for us, for us in the divine will. So let's come to
march the Ace, the state of victim of Jesus during his hidden life. This morning Father
G, this is very, very, very interesting, offered himself as a victim to our Lord. This Father
G, if you remember back to Volume 7 and 8, was the priest who decided to respond to the
invitation to put the priests into the reunions. Do you remember the reunions? Yes. And Father
G was the one who decided and now he's offered himself as a victim, which is very, very interesting.
He's offered himself as a victim to our Lord and I was praying, offering him, offering him
and ask the Lord to accept him. Then Jesus said, "My daughter, I accept him whole heartedly.
Imagine a priest offering himself." Very special. It was extremely special that Padre Pio was
a victim's soul in the 20th century. Tell him that his life will no longer be his, that's
escalations to 20. It will be mine and that I choose him as a victim of my hidden life.
Now, this is the first time I've come across this. I haven't come across this anywhere
else. I've heard St. Therese offered herself as a victim to divine love, Louisa to divine
justice. I think Padre Pio was the divine justice. I've never heard anybody offering
themselves as a victim to the hidden life. Okay. This is very special. My hidden life
was that of a victim for the whole interior life of man. So, it's satisfied for the bad
thoughts, desires, tendencies and affections. Everything that man does externally is nothing
other than the outpouring of his interior. That's Mark 721, Mark 721 and Jeremiah 17,
9 to 10. Now, in Mark 721, Jesus says, "It's not something that goes into view that spoils
you. It's what comes out of you." And he gives a big, long list of sins. So, it's the outpouring
of his interior. If so much evil shows on the outside, what must the interior be like?
Now, beside that, I want you to put Matthew 23. That's where Jesus, in the end, told
the scribes and Pharisees what he saw was on their inside. Therefore, 23. No, the whole
chapter, Matthew 23. It's the whole chapter. So, if so much evil is shown on the outside,
what must the interior be like? Therefore, the redoing of the interior of man cost me
very much. This is extremely important because it's in the hidden life that Jesus dedicated
his whole being to redoing us. Therefore, the redoing of the interior of man cost me
very much. It's enough to say that it took me as long as 30 years. So, put a big heading
up here redoing human nature. Redoing human nature. So, if you ever need the title, you'll
find it again. Now, my thought, my heartbeat, breath and desire, were always intent on running
close to the thought, the heartbeat, the breath and desire of man, in order to repair them,
to satisfy for them, and to sanctify them. So, I chose Father G as a victim for this
point of my hidden life, and I want all of his interior united with me. And I wanted
offered to me to satisfy me for the evil interior of other souls. I choose him for this on purpose
because being a priest, he knows better than others what the interior of souls is like.
Why is that? Because here's confession here. Okay. He knows the rot and the slime that
is actually in them. From this, he can better know how much my state of victim cost me,
a state in which I want him to take part and not only him, but others as well, whom he
will approach. Notice that, that he's to go to other priests and ask other priests to
make this reparation. Now, if priests would make reparation like this, the church would
come on, the ship would study very, very quickly because their position is very powerful. So,
he said, "My daughter, tell the priest that I am giving him a great grace by accepting
him as a victim soul because becoming a victim soul is nothing other than a second baptism,
that that really needs to be underlined. That means the old life stops and a completely
new life starts. Or rather, it's more than a baptism because it is about rising again
in my very life. So, it means that the old life is dead and he rises to a completely
new life in Christ. And since the victim soul must live with me and from me, it is necessary
for me to wash him of every stain, giving him a new baptism, strengthening him in grace
to be able to admit him to live with me. In other words, being a victim soul requires
a person to have arrived at union with God. Someone at a lesser stage has far too much
purification to go through. Therefore, from now on, in anything the priest does, he will
no longer say that it is his own, but that it is mine. So, whether he prays, speaks,
or works, he will say that these are my things. So, after this, Jesus seemed to be looking
around and I said, "Lord, what are you looking at? Aren't we alone?" He said, "No, there
are other people here." "I draw them around you," he said, "to have them closer to me."
That is a huge statement. So, Jesus is speaking to him on a spiritual level now that he draws
souls closer to Louisa, to have them closer to him. If you draw people close to a fire,
you warm them. Louisa said, "Do you love them?" Imagine asking Lord, "Do you love
anybody?" He said, "Yes, but I'd like them to be more at ease, more trusting, more brave,
and more intimate with me with no thought about themselves. They must know that victims are
no longer the masters of themselves, otherwise they would annul the state of victim." Now,
something else there. Jesus has brought all of our souls close to Louisa. Isn't that right?
Okay. So, he says, and I'm talking to each person in the room now, including myself,
"I want you to be more at ease with me," Jesus is saying, "I want you to be more trusting of me.
I want you to be more brave, and I want you to be more intimate with me,
and an awful lot less thought about yourself." Isn't that brilliant? That is absolutely direct.
Okay. So, then having to cough a little, Louisa said, "Jesus, let me come soon. Let me die of
consumption." Now, consumption was the thing in 1912. There's a huge TV problem. Actually,
Saint Therese of Lesus died of TV. She said, "Hurry, hurry." She said, "Let me come, take me with you."
And Jesus said, "Don't make me see your discontent." It's only 1912, and she used to go as far as 1947,
as far as I know. Yes, you will die of consumption just a little longer, he said. But if you don't die
of corporal consumption, in other words, he's saying, "You got the wrong illness." She actually
died of pneumonia. You will die of the consumption of love, which is a different subject.
"Oh, please, do not go out of my will." Notice how she's still free. She's free. She's free. She's free.
She's free. "Don't go out of my will, for my will will be your paradise, or better still,
the paradise of my will." For as much this now, I think this is unbelievable. For as many days
that you will be on the earth, so many paradises will give you in heaven. Now, I did a little bit
of mathematics on it. There's 365 days in the earth. You multiply it by 82. Okay? And you get 29,930
paradises than she got. Didn't you do well? She did pretty well.